well his premiership has been many
things but you couldn't say it wasn't
memorable
this morning i i went to
buckian palace
and i am forming a new government
tonight we are leaving the european
union for many people this is an
astonishing moment of hope
i was at a hospital the other night
where i think there were a few there
were actually a few coronavirus patients
and i shook hands with everybody uh
you'll be pleased to know i must give
the british people a very simple
instruction
you must stay at home now i'm just
hearing at this moment that the prime
minister has been taken into an
intensive care unit
we've been asking for action
as you know on coal cars cash and trees
ukraine
will win
[Music]
and britain
will be by
your side all guidance was followed
completely during number ten i apologize
i apologize unreservedly for the offense
that it has caused up and down the
country we're just hearing that uh
sajid javid has resigned i think rishi
sunak has just resigned as we've seen at
westminster
the herd instinct is powerful when the
herd moves it moves i want to thank
everybody here and
hasta la vista
baby thank you
[Applause]
has hasta la vista baby well one person
who knows boris johnson better than most
is lord lister eddie lister who's been
by his side
all the way back to when he was mayor of
london and i think we can see a couple
of photos of him here he is by boris
johnson's side at the announcement of
the winner of the conservative party
leadership in 2019 he then became mr
johnson's chief strategic advisor and
then downing street chief of staff so if
you want to know about boris johnson
he's a man you want to talk to and here
he is thank you very much for being with
us today
you know as i'm you know i'm looking
forward to interviewing you because i
feel like you perhaps know boris johnson
better than anyone i've actually
interviewed before on this program so
you know when on tuesday he you travels
to baramural to
meet with the queen how do you think
he's going to be feeling oh very sad um
i mean this is a job he always wanted
and um
it is it was the pinnacle of his um
political career and so he's going to be
very sad that day and uh he's also going
to look back and he's going to
um i am sure
just
just feel that you know what if it's the
old what if business what if some things
were done differently would it have
ended up like this it's hard to ever
know but it's not going to be a nice
journey for him you say what if and of
course as you say this is a man who
always wanted to be you know prime
minister i think he once talked about
wanting to be world king when he was a
child okay so remember that um
do you feel that he'll be frustrated
that he didn't even manage three years
on the job
oh yes yes of course i mean and and i
mean he has been um taken out of that
role before his time um and but but i
mean i think it's
naive to believe that the party was or
mps were not going to go for him at
various times um and so
to some extent he's he's been
on ice for a little bit a bit of a while
now um while he's dealt with some of
these various issues do you think that
his premiership will be seen as a
success
i think in hindsight yes um because i
think he has achieved a lot what what
specifically well i think the first
thing um has to be of course that he
defeated jeremy corbyn um and jeremy
corbyn could have brought in and he was
a very strong candidate and could have
brought in a labor government a very
left-wing labour
government campaigning success isn't it
what as prime minister well immediately
you must move on i think to brexit
brexit was completed and achieved
against enormous opposition in
parliament enormous opposition within
the courts and it was a very painful
process he completed that he also um was
the prime minister over covet and
undoubtedly and perhaps we could talk
about this i don't know um he it was his
drive to get vaccines which you have to
credit him with that above every anybody
else um but that was a tough time and
then of course ukraine
without his commitment to ukraine i
don't think
america or europe would have been as
robust as they are you know uncovered
because obviously you were right there
in the room where as many of those
decisions were happening you had a sort
of ringside seat
another person who did was dominic
cummings he has a very different take to
you he describes boris johnson as a
shopping trolley veering all over the
place in january he said it was his duty
to get rid of boris johnson's prime
minister saying it was sort of like
fixing the drains
so you got a point no
i'm sorry i i don't think he has and um
i'm very sorry that um
the dominic felt he could no longer work
for boris um he he was um he was a very
talented man um but i think he was just
playing wrong on this what you've got to
remember with covit is that right at the
beginning nobody knew anything
the advice was contradictory
everybody was saying different things
there was a moment in time where it was
um the the advisors were saying heard
immunity was the answer don't do
anything then the next one was you've
got to get vaccines that's the essential
one then it was don't wear masks they're
not they don't work then it was wear
masks the advice coming in to him
and like plenty of our examples was was
always contradictory so he had to make
judgments and you must remember it
nearly it nearly killed him so he was
very personal about it he knew what it
was like for people to have um to have
got to that point where they were
intensive care did it shake him that
that experience because you see the sort
of bombastic side of boris johnson you
know kind of shrugging it off trying to
get back to work the puppy gate trying
to stop him from you know going down to
refusing to isolate from number two that
wasn't right no
yes it did shake him it did shake him i
always remember one one conversation and
it was one of those many conversations
done i i can't remember now where it was
done on the zoom from within the
building it was done shouting through
the door um but it was it was he was
went into a coughing fit he said god
this is awful
that was i think the first time i
realized that he was ill really ill
because he's not somebody who reacts to
illness at all and that was the moment
um so it did shake him yes
i think there was a lot of anger of
course as well about the feeling that
rules were stretched and in some cases
broken
in downing street when everyone else had
to follow the rules i mean you were
there at the time were you at any of
those parties that were investigated no
i wasn't um but then
come friday night i wouldn't want to be
around downing street i wanted to go
home um and and to be absolutely fair um
he wasn't either i mean a lot he
received a fine from the police yes he
did for for a particular incident yes he
did and that was that was the one where
um he as a surprise um
suddenly brought him in a birthday cake
um just before the start of a meeting
and rishi sanak also got a fine for that
as well i always thought that was deeply
unfair actually because he didn't set
out to have a surprise birthday cake
that was actually just before i can't
even remember now today what meeting
that was it was one i wasn't at so i i
don't know
um but no what i was going to say was
that most of the the incidents of
parties were not parties as you or i
know them they were people um
some of the younger staff having having
a drink um at the end of a friday when
they when they've been there all week
remember nobody was at home they were
all in the building there are these
questions about integrity which
in the end led to boris johnson's
downfall you know whether it was being
fined by the police over over party gate
his handling of these allegations of
sexual misconduct with chris pincher
frankly his relationship with the truth
as well he's been investigated over
whether he misled parliament
many people look at him and think this
is not a man of integrity i don't agree
um he is
i've never known somebody um quite as
tough on this as him he is
a very very straightforward individual
he would never knowingly break the law
that is not him he genuinely i mean
those instances you talked about
um kevin and he's apologized for them um
he did not believe he was breaking the
law he wouldn't have done it if he
believed that there have also been
questions about your own uh conduct as
well uh while they're in in government
you're also director of edward lister
consultants an advisor to the property
group de lansi non-executive director to
stan hope holdings
is that not a conflict of interest not
really no um
no no firstly they were all declared i
mean let me be quite clear about that
and secondly um i was i was still doing
a little bit of work there for myself
but it was nothing to do with any
government work it was all to do with
very specific
work for in fact it was largely shut
down while i was in parliament so no i
don't believe there was anything and and
certainly it was all stuff that i
declared but if it's declared does that
not mean if you just declare it then you
can effectively just do it
i suppose you could do it that way but i
didn't i virtually did nothing while i
was so why did anything at all then if
it was virtually not well because i when
i went into downing street i went in for
a very short period of time i was
originally going in for three months
um and and then that changed to get
brexit done um in the general election
and then just as i was going to leave
kovitz struck so i stayed longer than i
ever planned to stay
and that was that was the reason
in hindsight i should have completely
got rid of those things but how much
money were you making oh it wasn't much
it was very little what what does that
mean no no i'm not going to go okay in
fact i'm not that's pretty sure
but it was it was it was very small
let's look forward uh the new prime
minister uh is going to be we're going
to find out who it's going to be
tomorrow who would you like it to be
i think now um
and and having watched the debate as
it's unfolded i i think liz trusts
because i i am one of those who believe
that you can't do what you've always
done and get the same result and so i
think we do need to change
and i think the proposal she's putting
forward are going to bring about a lot
of change i think they're going to be
very hard it's going to be very
difficult i wouldn't end envy anybody
entering into downing street um on
tuesday it's going to be tough but i
think she's probably the best person for
the job you know as you say it is going
to be tough uh the the situation that
they're going to find themselves in in
number 10 and number 11 is is going to
be almost sort of unprecedented in
memory
what policy platform would you like her
to take forward
i think the important thing is she's got
to deal with the big issues she's got to
continue boris johnson's legacy over
ukraine and got to stay robust over
ukraine because i still believe that's
the single most dangerous issue that's
out there i know it's it's not top of
everybody's list but it is the most
dangerous one um the second one is of of
course cost of living and she's putting
forward a number of proposals on that
she's talked about tax cuts she's talked
about um some targeted help she's not
spelled that out yet and i'm sure she
will be doing that and she's also um
talked about a rethink about energy and
i think that's right because we it's not
just a short-term problem there's also a
long-term problem here that needs to be
dealt with
there are some reports
that conservative mps and members are
experiencing a bit of sellers remorse
over boris johnson
well so they should
sorry
i mean i i i just think they um
i think they did the wrong thing i i
think they overreacted i think they
they got too much into their twitter
accounts and um stopped um thinking
straight and i don't think it was a good
move i think he's the best prime
minister we've had i think he would
continue to be a good prime minister i
think he would be very successful in a
further general election however that's
yesterday that's gone um
so has it gone do you think we might be
tempted oh well maybe in the future i'd
never say never on anything with with
boris johnson um
anything is possible in the future but
for now we have a new leader and as as
he said yesterday um the party now needs
to rally behind and the mps need to
rally behind the new leader so never say
never do you think he will it may be
that he gives liz trust a chance sees
what happens but
if as someone once said the ball came
loose at the back of the scrum
look you he's he is an amazing person he
is full of energy he works extremely
hard he is going to be watching all this
and if something happens in the future
as you said with the ball comes loosen
the scrum then
then all things anything can happen i'm
not going to predict all i'm saying is
i would never say i would never write
him off okay thank you very much
fascinating to uh talk lordless to there
thank you